german chancellor olaf schultz he is in
canada tonight meeting his canadian
counterpart who
says that his country is looking at
delivering liquefied natural gas to
europe schultz is on a three-day visit
to canada hoping to find new sources of
energy as berlin tries to decrease its
dependence on russian energy now
speaking in montreal the leaders said
that russia's war in ukraine demands a
short-term boost to fossil fuels even as
they remain focused on renewable energy
and fighting climate change long term
now the chancellor highlighted the
similarities that germany and canada
share that help them work together take
a listen
there is a special
cooperation between canada and
and germany in all the questions that
are related to the future
so both the countries have the idea of
becoming
success of successfully fighting against
climate change
and so there's a lot of economic and
technological cooperation which benefits
the two countries because our industries
our business sectors and our political
representatives are working together to
make this happen
and when we now see that there is this
russian aggression against ukraine and
in the end to the rest of the world it
is absolutely necessary that we
accelerate these processes
there's still a big question though will
schultz's efforts to secure canadian
energy mean that people here in germany
can breathe a little bit more easily as
they head into a possibly very long and
cold winter we put that question to our
political correspondent nina haza she is
traveling with the german chancellor
yeah canada is not going to play a role
in helping germany overcome those
shortages that are being caused by of
course the lack of russian gas supplies
this winter this is something that
nobody's raising any expectations for
but what's important is to intensify
already existing bonds and
sign memorandums of understanding so
that both countries agree that they will
work together very closely when it comes
to that transformation of the industry
when it comes to making that green and
this is of course a medium to long-term
prospect but germany hopes that it can
convince canada to use some of its
untapped potential and also explore
liquid natural gas on the east coast and
then hopefully export that to germany so
and also more importantly perhaps use um
the hydrogen potential in the country
and there is the hope that in three to
six years time perhaps the first
hydrogen can be exported from canada to
germany earlier i spoke to energy
analyst thomas o'donnell about how much
green energy cooperation with canada can
help europe out with its current crisis
canada cannot supply any renewable
energy that will make any difference in
the current confrontation with russia
they're spending some time going to a a
small city
near the northern coast of canada i
believe in new brunswick to look at
where canada
says they will in the future
produce hydrogen green hydrogen now this
is sort of one of those things that's
very important to do when you meet a
german
chancellor and especially mr halbach the
green super minister of environment and
energy um but really what they're after
i think in the immediate is minerals
uh we can talk about that rare earths
and so forth and copper but also lng but
even that canada can't provide it for
some years lng
i wanted to take that up so trudeau was
asked when will canada deliver lng to
germany and how much he said he was
looking for the business case to do so
what does he mean by that exactly
uh that means he's not convinced he
should do it
there's something
i'll admit as the expert here i wrote
some articles on
germany's real lng policy
about four or five years ago in 2018
when the previous coalition decided in
its initial treaty
under merkel that they would fund and
support lng import terminals in northern
germany which were purely for liquid for
transportation but it never happened and
during that time one thing they did is
they said they were going to contribute
a half a million dollars
in canada on the coast for
building a facility that would export
lng
nothing ever happened afterwards
it was it died and here they are again
bringing it up and canada according to
trudeau seemingly isn't yet committed so
it doesn't sound like you think germany
should count on canadian lng but we're
seeing european energy prices spike
again this week after this announcement
of a three-day shutdown of nordstrom one
at the end of the month how do you rate
germany's chances of successfully
replacing shrinking gas supplies quickly
it's simply not possible
and don't take it on my authority uh
listen to mr mueller who's head of the
network agency for the natural gas
infrastructure in germany he says this
will be a crisis of two years if putin
cuts off the big pipelines he said this
publicly he's absolutely right if he
cuts off the big pipelines storage a
won't be filled if he cuts it off now b
if when he cuts it off later storage
isn't enough you can't replace those
huge pipeline imports
simply with storage after two three
months there's a debate now
it would run out and this would be a
quite a crisis and there's no reason to
believe this won't repeat for two years
it'll take that long to find other
supplies
from other countries
thank you very much energy analyst
thomas o'donnell there
you